and now i sadly
and with her heart broken over what this
means to our country
of a president who would sight
insurrection
will sign the engrossment of the article
of impeachment
in a historic moment donald trump is now
the first president to be impeached for
a
second time today in a bipartisan way
the house
demonstrated that no one is above the
law the house of representatives voted
for the impeachment on wednesday for
inciting the insurrection
at the capitol last week and celebrities
have taken to social media with their
reactions to the monumental event
chrissy teigen tweeted i didn't even
know you could be impeached twice
i thought it was like dying cardi b
posted this clip from her 73 questions
video with vogue
who is your least favorite president of
the united states america
the wonders gonna get impeached and
wrote this above the video
jesse tyler ferguson wrote trump will
have the legacy of doing a
really great job of getting impeached
better than any other president that's a
perfect
bigly accomplishment michael rappaport
posted this
expletive-packed message to twitter they
impeached you not once
twice two [ __ ] times you asked
don't do the crime if you can't do the
time
don't do it in response to the 10
republicans who crossed the political
aisle to vote for trump's impeachment
george takei tweeted the importance of
10 gop
house members voting to impeach is this
it shows that it's not about politics
it's about courage the truth is there
for those with guts enough to say it and
mean it
to the 10 with those guts your country
salutes you
president trump sought to overturn the
results of an election
and of a fair election he saw the coup
by misleading people with lies
it was just a few days ago that arnold
schwarzenegger posted this candid
message
speaking out against president trump
where the former governor of california
called him
the worst president ever president trump
is a failed leader
he will go down in history as the worst
president ever
the good thing is that he soon will be
as irrelevant as an
old tweet